so right
another great entry in the evil kid
genre which is wide ranging and
plentiful I'm wondering if there's any
evil child movie you jiron particularly
or whether you developed your evil child
persona by yourself um yeah I think a
lot of it was an independent thing
because I was trying to you know really
capture the fact that Riperton is its
own thing its own superhero [ __ ] new
genre you know superhero evil thing you
know and all of those smashed up words
combined but I did take a little bit of
inspiration from you know some classics
like um The Omen Sixth Sense things like
that mm-hmm
and basically this movie the way it's
being you know sold in the public is
it's the superior movie but it the
superior comes down and he's much more
evil because that's just sort of how it
happens I'm wondering if looking at you
know just the world and how people are
whether you think that might be the more
realistic path for an alien that came to
her oh I don't think so I mean I think
that Emmy really is a supervillain movie
more than a superhero movie you know I
think yeah I know I like to think that
that you know I like to look at the
world in hope that like if someone came
down here that they would try to do some
good but but yeah I don't know that's a
good question yeah it is human nature to
maybe kind of lean towards you know
doing the doing the better thing it's
kind of you know our qualms and such but
um he's not human so we really have no
idea well that's actually I'm kind of
curious because I believe you have it
you have a son
I do and I'm wondering if you know have
been hypothetically you know son grows
up lazy will start coming out of his
eyes what is the what's the move there
what is the first move well that would
be terrifying yeah I think you know I I
would act much quicker than
I'll does had some signs of travel
I wouldn't adopt an alien baby and that
would be the first thing I would avoid
yeah no I mean I think I think what's
fun about this movie for me is watching
the conflict between the mother and the
father and the mother only seeing the
good and the potential and their child
and and the father having being
skeptical freely from the get-go
and and then but he's lived a pretty
normal childhood up until this point he
started to go through puberty and then
this is what things start to change so
they're a little slow on the uptake of
what's happening and there are some red
flags that pop out that that that the
dad is starting you know kylo starting
to point out and and but by the time
they figure it out it's just too little
too late and I think I think if my son
were evil I would I would hopefully be
able to see it a lot quicker and do
something about it okay I'm very curious
about the the practical nature of this
film and I feel like the the most
unsettling thing about Brandon is just
when he's just sort of floating there
and I'm wondering how often that was
practical how often they sort of just
you know strung you up and had you float
around but was it ever practical was
that all sepia oh yeah no there were
times where I was you know in a harness
or you know using some other film trick
that you can see to to be floating or
flying and then often times it was just
uncouple to UM there's a fair share of
CGI moments but I think it actually is
more more than practical forever at
least of the up-close floating scenes
and was that that's very helpful for you
to just you know all day not all day but
you know for take after take you're just
sort of floating there was that helpful
for you yeah I mean I think it helped me
capture the essence of the character a
little bit to be actually living a lot
of the parts of my life that the
character was